[Musique]
nous sommes dans le poumon économique de
l'italie
la lombardie cette région pèse un tiers
du pib national
c'est ici que nous venons mesurer les
effets du job act une ambitieuse réforme
du marché du travail mis en place il ya
un peu plus de deux ans par le
gouvernement renzi pour relancer emploi
et croissance
première étape polenghi cette pme
produit des jus de citron comme souvent
en italie
c'est une entreprise familiale le gérant
marco polenghi et fils du fondateur
pour lui le job act a été une petite
révolution sur les 62 salariés du site
19 ont été recrutés grâce à ce plan une
vague d'embauchés inédite dans
l'histoire de l'entreprise
[Musique]
le problème principal pour nous c'était
la complexité des contrats mais aussi
leur hétérogénéité
cela ne nous permettait pas d'avoir une
gestion linéaire et simple de nos
employés le droit du travail italien
était l'un des plus protecteurs pour les
salariés les licenciements impliqué des
procédures très complexes
les contrats du job act introduisent une
période d'essai de trois ans et des
droits sociaux qui s'acquiert avec
l'ancienneté de la flexisécurité donc
puisque ces contrats restent à durée
indéterminée ceux qui les ont signés
dans un contexte de crise et de chômage
élevé semble ici plutôt convaincu les
salariés on sait que plus on travaille
plus on va sortir de la crise et on
n'est plus responsable si on a un
contrat à durée indéterminée une
responsabilité dans le sens où on est
redevable par rapport à notre employeur
sept cent mille cdi de ce nouveau type
ont été signés en italie le chômage a
reculé d'un peu moins de 2 points et la
croissance 1 mollement rebondit un bilan
correct mais le job act a aussi coûté
très cher pour booster ce plan le
gouvernement a accordé sur les deux
premières années d'énormes avantages aux
employeurs exonération totale de
cotisations sociales pendant un an puis
de 40 % l'année suivante
pour ses détracteurs ce plan est en fait
un grand bluff
il ya une dépense énorme d'argent public
qui aurait pu être utilisé ailleurs et
si nous regardons en détail nous voyons
que beaucoup d'employés ont des contrats
plus précaires plus discontinues qu'ils
passent d'un contrat à l'autre avec des
salaires plus bas salaires les plus bas
c'est la précarité
un mal lancinant en italie angelo emilia
connaissent le refrain parker leur
génération a toujours connu des
conditions de travail instable le job
act n'a rien arrangé pour eux au
contraire ça je peux le dire avec mes
mots bien sûr le plan renzi c'est de la
merde
cela a été la touche finale d'un plan de
dérégulation du monde du travail entamé
depuis plus de 15 en italie en 2015
angelo a signé un contrat jobs act qui a
remplacé ce que son employeur lui
faisait signer depuis trois ans mais
cinq mois plus tard il a été licencié
résultat il n'a pas touché les
indemnités correspondant à son
ancienneté réel et milliards elle est
professeur des écoles dans le public
le job act a aussi changé en profondeur
le statut des enseignants elle est
titularisée
mais n'est lié à son établissement
actuel que pour trois ans c'est son
directeur qui décidera ensuite de son
maintien ou non dans cette école et des
dj's et a souvent rencontré des managers
les directeurs d'école doivent assumer
une fonction de manager ils ont la
liberté d'embauché ou de licencier le
personnel scolaire
au bout de trois ans dans une école nous
pouvons être contraint de faire des
démarches auprès d'autres directeurs et
si cela n'aboutit pas notre mutation est
décidée par un simple algorithmes
un poste à la pérennité incertaine un
salaire modeste 1300 euros par mois à
bientôt 40 ans emilie a du mal à se
projeter dans l'avenir
mon compagnon a également un contrat
jobs act nous avons essayé auprès de
plusieurs banques de simuler un prêt
pour acheter un logement
à chaque fois le prêt nous a été refusée
il nous sentons aussi précaire qu'avant
et cela ne nous aide pas envisager de
former une famille complète ce que
craignent emilia et angelo c'est que le
job act ne soit un tremplin vers une
dérégulation plus globale du marché du
travail
ces hommes sont des représentants de la
patronale de lombardie nous les
rencontrons chez homère un gros
sous-traitant automobile qui fournit
ferrari et maserati pour ces gros
employeur le job act ne va pas encore
assez loin
le job act et de début d'un changement
plus radical du monde du travail
l'entreprise est le moteur la nourriture
de l'économie européenne et mondiale
aujourd'hui à la lumière des événements
à des phénomènes mondiaux nous devons
repenser le modèle social pour qu'ils
soient plus adapté on ne peut
redistribuer la richesse qu une fois que
la richesse est produit le virage
économique initiée avec le job act sera
validé ou sanctionner dans les urnes au
printemps prochain à l'occasion des
élections législatives
[Musique]